one is
every time a person died they would
always say
my father or my mother is already in
heaven
even adventists would post on facebook
telling them that my father just went to
heaven
because they're dead so how do we
enlighten them that's one of the
cardinal teachings of the church
dead people are in the grave
i all right let me uh
let me be patient it's a virtue
go to genesis 2 please genesis 2.
do you have a little pulpit i can put my
there's no little pulpit
right here i can put my bible on no no
no can i have that chair please
and god bless you for your decision god
bless you god bless you god bless you
god bless you
all right do we have genesis 2 let me
pray father
i'm discussing where people go after
death this was the devil this continues
to be
one of the false doctrines the devil
uses to deceive the whole world
give me a simple explanation i pray in
jesus name
amen genesis 2 let's read verse
7. what does that say and the lord god
formed man of the dust of the ground
breathed into his nostrils the breath of
life
and man became what a living soul now
from what was adam made
the dust of the ground is that clear
go to verse 19.
read with me and out of the ground the
lord god formed every beast of the earth
and every fowl of the air and brought
them unto adam to see what he would call
them
and whatsoever adam called every living
creature that was the name thereof
salamat salamat my good brother god
bless you
thank you so much you're a good man all
right
question for you from what was adam
made from what were the animals made
dust okay are you with me
dust go to ecclesiastes chapter 3.
verse 19 listen very carefully if you're
certainly out of this even if you're not
listen carefully ecclesiastes 3
reading verse 19. read with me
for that which befalleth the sons of men
be fallen stop what does the word
befalleth mean
to happen the bible says what happens to
us
happens to animals keep reading
even even one thing before he follows
them the same thing
keep reading that's the one diet so die
of the other stop
at the physical level we die
the way animals die the bible says it's
one death
read the next statement carefully yay
they have all
one breath
the breath of life in me is the breath
of life in a dog
i said at the physical level yeah are
you following me
amen finish the verse now so that a man
if you go to a cemetery for pets
and you dig up one of the graves what
will you find
come on dust and bones
if you dig up a cemetery for human
beings what will you find
dust and bones because the bible says
they have the same flesh
they have the same breath they die the
same way
now verse 20
all go unto one place come on
all out of the dust all turn to dust
again
now what's so difficult about that what
does the bible say
all go where one place where's that
now this is the root of the truth
of where the dead go when they die if
you say
a dead man goes to heaven you also have
to say
his dead dog goes with him
because the bible says they go away the
same
place read verse 21 now
carefully who knoweth
the spirit of man that it goeth upward
and the spirit of it goeth how can you
say the bible say
a man of death goes up and an animal
goes down how can you say that the bible
says
they go the same place now there is a
reason for that
and we find it of course in the first
three chapters of genesis
go to genesis 3. we're looking at the
root
of this teaching genesis 3.
do you have genesis 3 let's read from
verse 17.
adam has sinned following his wife god
deals with the wife in verse 16.
now he talks to adam is everyone
listening
verse 17 read with me and unto adam he
said
because thou has hearkened unto the
voice of thy wife
and has eaten of the tree of which i
commanded thee saying
thou shalt not eat of it cursed is the
ground
for thy sake keep reading in sorrow
shalt thou eat of it
all the days of thy life keep reading
thorns
also and thistles shall it bring forth
unto thee and thou
shalt eat the herb of the field verse 19
in the sweat of thy face shalt thou eat
bread
come on till thou wat return
onto the ground keep reading for
out of it was now taken care
for dust thou art and unto thou shalt
thou return
now think with me
when god is talking to adam is adam
alive yes or no
yes but what does god call him
what does god call him look at verse 19.
dust
he calls him dust now verse 7 says of
chapter 2 just listen
and the lord god form man of the dust of
the ground breathed into his nostrils
the breath of life
man became a living soul listen to me
carefully adam was not made from
dust and breath he was made from dust
the breath brought the dust to life
listen to me again
adam was made from dust so when god is
talking to him
god doesn't say dust and breath thou art
he just says
dust thou art and unto thou shalt thou
return now
we have a principle it is called the
principle
of return now how could god tell adam
till thou return unto the dust how can
god say that
now tomorrow i am returning to united
states that's where i came from
how many of you have ever been to
bangladesh can i see your hand
bangladesh i have been there so i can
return are you following me i can return
why does god tell adam until thou return
onto the ground what does he mean by
that
that's where you came from and when you
die
finish my words that's where you go now
god made adam from dust where did god
find the dust
on the earth where did the breath come
from
uh-huh why could adam not go back to
heaven or go to heaven
that's not where you're rich that's not
where he came from there's no dust in
heaven
he came from the dust now if he had been
made of breath
ah he could have gone back no he was
made from dirt
so he has to go back are you following
me yes
go to genesis 18 listen to abraham
genesis 18. we read from verse 25
genesis 18 read it for verse 25
do you have that let me pray father in
heaven
i am still explaining this very very
vital subject speak through me dear god
in jesus name i pray
amen read for me what's that saying
that be far from thee to what
destroy to do after this matter to the
slow the wicked
the righteous with the wicked and that
the righteous should be as the wicked
abraham is telling god you cannot
destroy the righteous with the wicked
that be far from thee shall not the
judge of all the earth they were right
and the lord said if i fight in sodom
45 i will do what i will not destroy
verse 27 read for me and abraham
answered the lord and said what behold
i have taken upon me to speak unto the
lord now how does he describe himself
which and but dust and ashes that's all
i am
he does not say i am dust and breath go
to psalm 103.
psalm 103
i hope you're listening i really do
do you have that let's read verse 14.
let's read 13 and 14 are you there read
with me
like as a father pity is his children
that fear him now read verse 14
carefully for he knows our frame that
was
how we were made he remembered that we
are dust not that we're dust and breath
so over and over we read we are dust
and god's principle is you go back to
where you came from
now no matter what you read in luke
about lazarus and rich man
you have to stick with this foundation
which is
the dead go back to where they came from
luke
cannot preach something different from
that
i said all of that to say any adventists
will know
when you die you're in the grave just
like jesus
the bible says david is not ascended
into heaven his sepulcher is still with
us
he's in the grave if you were in heaven
there was no need for christ to come
back are you following me
to raise the dead because they're
already alive
it is there are two doctrines false
the devil uses to deceive most of the
world doctrine one
the first day of the week is holy
doctrine two dead people are not really
dead
two he uses to deceive the whole world